[Music]
on this tuesday night another discovery
on the site of a former residential
school
what are believed to be more than 160
unmarked graves on a bc gulf island
there's nowhere to run there's nowhere
to hide the stories of survivors and the
search for the missing
the tragic consequences of that crane
collapse in kelowna
those guys that were there they had
children and wives
good people the victims the witnesses
and the investigation
the pandemic's impact on a baby's
immunity their microbes are being
screwed up
advice for parents on what to expect in
the months ahead
and pouring salt into a stanley cup
sized wound
why hockey's holy grail is now headed to
the home of the habs
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
another indigenous community has
revealed it has discovered what it calls
undocumented and unmarked grapes
in an area that was once home to a
residential school
penelocut island formerly known as
cooper island
is near vancouver island in bc the
cooper island industrial school operated
there between 1890 and 1975
and it's on those grounds that the
penelope tribe says
at least 160 graves have been found
the catholic church ran the school until
a federal government took it over in
1969
it closed six years later since the
first announcement in kamloops bc last
month
more than thirteen hundred suspected
unmarked graves have been identified
at four former residential school sites
three in bc
and one in saskatchewan and it is
expected there will be many more
kylie stanton has our top story tonight
on the latest revelation
for students here it became known as
alcatraz
an island prison the path to escape
forever in sight
the watery depths too far across to
safely swim
there's nowhere to run there's nowhere
to hide it's an island that's
one of the key memories that i recall
from attending the school was
wanting to run away from the 1890s to
1970s the cooper island industrial
school
operated on what's now known as
pinellicht island
now the penelope tribe confirms the
discovery of more than 160
undocumented and unmarked graves on the
former school site within their
territory
i admit i wasn't terribly surprised
chief and council decided it was time to
announce
that the work they had been doing and
the numbers that they have in a letter
informing neighboring first nations
communities
chief joan brown writes it is impossible
to get over the acts of genocide and
human rights violations
healing is an ongoing process and
sometimes it goes well
and sometimes we lose more people
because the burden
is too great i hated it
there's lots of anger lots of hate but
most of all
it's just like lots of sorrow because
i was no longer a kid the school was
officially closed in 1975.
five years later the building was
demolished but the pain remains
real for generations of survivors still
experiencing trauma
the whole abuse stayed deep within my
heart
my soul i would not allow it to come out
global news has reached out to the
penelope tribe for further information
but officials have not yet returned
calls for comment
it's believed ground penetrating radar
was used in this investigation
and there is still more work to be done
what will likely only add to the number
of suspected graves reported to be found
right across the country to members of
the penelope tribe
we are here for you we cannot bring back
those who are lost but we can and we
will
continue to tell the truth but survivors
who
are well aware of the truth are calling
for action
and accountability after similar
discoveries in british columbia and
saskatchewan
with searches now underway across the
country
this they say is just the beginning i
think
canadians better prepare themselves for
more announcements
as more of this work starts to ramp up
over the next year or two
another painful reminder of canada's
past that will almost certainly
not be the last kelly stanton global
news victoria
there is support for those who need it
the indian residential school
survivors crisis line is available in
canada 24 hours a day
the number is toll-free and you can
speak in confidence it's 1-866-925-4419
now to another developing story in bc
that deadly
crane collapse at a construction site in
kelowna police are calling what happened
catastrophic and tonight the city
remains under a state of emergency
as crews try to stabilize the mangled
wreckage four men who worked at the site
were killed and a fifth man is missing
and presumed dead police say he was
working in a nearby
office and is buried under the rubble
robin gill reports
from kelowna tons of steel that were
part of the kelowna skyline for months
just seemed to buckle the broken pieces
of the crane tumbled to the ground
taking the lives of four construction
workers
shay cosgrove worked with the men and is
gutted by the loss of his work family
those guys that were there they had
children and wives
good people
one worker was seen dangling from
stories up but managed to shimmy to
safety
eric trudell the site safety officer
says his colleague was determined to
survive
i talked to him when he was on the cross
beam i was on the sixth floor and i just
told him to keep going
and tried to get to the building the
high-rise is a project by mission group
a well-known development company in
kelowna
the company had hired stemmers
construction for the crane
the crane was in the process of being
dismantled when it came crashing down
two brothers eric and patrick stemmer
the crane operator were killed
along with jared zuk of edmonton why
exactly
that crane collapsed that's a part of
the investigation i simply don't know
the answer and i certainly couldn't
speculate
obviously something catastrophic
occurred this is one of canada's worst
crane disasters in a city making an
economic rebound
this is an epic engineering failure
this is crazy paul nesbitt was working
in a nearby office when the crane came
down
all of a sudden the whole building
started rumbling
so you could actually feel the crane
coming apart and then all of a sudden it
was this
massive bang it's shaken kelowna and the
local construction industry
people that take this apart are usually
quite safe and they have all the
safety mechanisms in place but i'm not
too sure what happened but obviously
something
but it did happen to men who thought it
was just a normal day
on the job and it was supposed to be a
regular day for a fifth person who was
killed in an adjacent building that was
hit by the crane
and tonight crews and equipment that
specialize in these kinds of disasters
have been brought in to stabilize the
situation
so that his body can be recovered donna
all right robin gill in kelowna thanks
now to covet 19 canada has surpassed
another vaccination milestone
more than 50 percent of canadians age 12
and up are now
fully vaccinated and about 79 percent
have received at least one dose
a college in ontario says it's decided
to make vaccines
mandatory for those who go to school in
september
toronto seneca college says the rule
will apply to any students or staff who
want to participate in on-campus
activities
the college says it's not forcing anyone
to get vaccinated but
students who choose not to will have to
learn online
it just seemed honestly like the right
thing to do and the logical thing to do
it just it keeps our community safe
whether covid vaccinations should be
mandatory is a hot topic
this week both france and greece
announced new measures to provide
vaccinated people with privileged access
to activities such as eating indoors and
going to shopping malls and cinemas
they're also making immunization
mandatory for health care workers
abigail beeman looks at the arguments
for and against
and where canadian provinces stand in
the debate
this physical therapist says she'll be
vaccinated against her will to keep her
job
mixed reaction in france to the
president's announcement all health care
workers need the jab
when it comes to high-risk patient
groups especially when you think about
you know long-term care when you think
about our oncology
and and immuno-suppressed populations i
think it's
it's possible the benefit outweighs the
downside
in canada colvit case numbers are lower
and vaccination rates higher but the
push is still on
we expect every care worker to be
vaccinated
and if it's not the case there will be
consequences for that only a few
provinces have mandated vaccines and
only sort of
quebec has the broadest rules since
april healthcare workers who interact
with patients
have had to show proof of vaccination or
be subject to testing three times a week
ontario nbc target long-term care staff
in ontario they must show proof of
vaccination provide a medical reason as
to why they can't
or take part in an educational program
about the benefits
in bc new rules take effect next week
requiring
unvaccinated workers to wear a mask and
take regular
rapid tests we're going to continue to
use the education model
there is choice when it comes to who
gets vaccinated
we are going to continue to do what is
necessary by
giving canadians the information by
making it easy to get vaccinated
the head of the registered nurses
association of ontario says she would
likely support a government move to make
vaccinations mandatory for her members
acknowledging there are still some
vaccine hesitant or even anti-vaxxer
nurses we are talking about a
insidious mutating
virus so these folks who are concerned
about mandatory vaccines have nothing to
be concerned about
and there will be no vaccine passports
vaccine passports the other hot topic
advancing globally while canada doesn't
yet have a clear national plan
provincially alberta is most opposed
ontario hasn't yet planned for one
while quebec is moving ahead with a
regional-based system
requiring proof of vaccination only for
non-essential activities in specific
places
during outbreaks only abigail beeman
global news
ottawa one side effect of all the public
health restrictions is a big reduction
in the usual seasonal illnesses like
cold and flu and childhood viruses
that also means young children haven't
been exposed to the germs that help
build immunity
now as people begin to gather again
parents are being told to prepare
for things to change jamie morocco
explains
like so many other pandemic mothers
victoria reed has spent much of
maternity leave in social isolation
my plans for you know mom groups and
doing
baby yoga and all of that stuff sort of
fell by the wayside a little bit
for little holly it's meant less
interaction with new friends and
less exposure to germs only that's not
necessarily a good thing
these kids are being immune and deprived
and their microbes are being screwed up
so their immune systems are a bit
screwed up
called immunity debt it's what doctors
explain as a lack of immune stimulation
due to a reduction in exposure to
viruses the countries that have been
had have applied quite successful
measures to stop
cover 19 transmission in the community
we'll be seeing these effects
wellington-based epidemiologist michael
baker says in new zealand
reopening has led to a resurgence in a
serious respiratory illness known as rsv
and the surge he says is putting a
strain on local pediatric wards
there were a thousand cases
a week ago and that's you know almost
the number we might have for it for a
whole
winter a recent study found countries
like new zealand aren't alone
australia is also facing a rise in rsv
cases as lockdown measures lift
and experts say canada isn't immune
either
i think we're going to see a big spike
in that in kids the next year so
back in calgary where stampede is in
full swing reed says she plans to steer
clear of crowds
wash her hands and socialize holly
slowly
i do think it's also important to try to
ease back into life
so you know her immune system can be
built up ultimately experts say parents
shouldn't worry babies born during the
pandemic have a
less than immune system kids don't need
to catch a severe illness to create
robust immunity
vaccinations and simple hygiene are
still the best course of action
donna all right jamie morocco
thanks nova scotia has become the second
province after bc to sign a deal with
the federal government to fund
child care the plan is to lower the
average cost of child care to ten
dollars a day by
2026 for children under the age of six
and prime minister justin trudeau claims
by the end of next year average child
care fees will be cut in half
for families here with young kids this
will make a huge difference
within two years we're going to create
four thousand new spaces
and nine thousand five hundred more over
the next five years
the federal funding was revealed in the
last federal budget and is also meant to
help with before and after school care
today's announcement was made as
speculation grows an election
may be called soon in nova scotia and
speculation is also swirling about a
possible
federal election soon climate change
should be on the agenda hot spells on
the prairies are common but
sustained high temperatures and lack of
rain right now is happening
earlier and blistering heat is hurting
farmers in manitoba the municipality
of armstrong is in day four of an
agricultural disaster
a severe drought has led to a major
shortage of feed and now
grasshoppers are decimating what's left
of the crops and vegetation
the municipality is asking for
provincial and federal help for farmers
last week the neighboring rural
municipality of saint laurent declared
an
agricultural disaster too wildfires are
also a problem in manitoba at least
87 are burning now with danger levels
rated high to
extreme new fire and travel restrictions
come into effect in parts of the
province tomorrow
including a ban on campfires and back
country travel
and in bc there are more than 300
wildfires burning
the largest has flared back up forcing
evacuations north of kamloops
the sparks lake wildfire has now burned
more than 40 000 hectares
about half the province is also dealing
with poor air quality caused by the
smoke
bc has already passed a thousand fires
this season
in an average year there are thirteen
hundred
the worst violence to hit south africa
in decades coming up the outrage over a
former president's imprisonment
plus what's up with these huge goldfish
widespread unrest and rioting is
continuing in south africa the country's
president says it's the worst violence
since the end of apartheid 27 years ago
police say more than 70 people are dead
10 of them were crushed in a stampede as
looters ransacked a mall
more than 1200 people have been arrested
and food and fuel are now in short
supply in areas hit hard by the protests
the country's currency has taken a dive
this all started after south africa's
former president jacob zuma turned
himself into authorities last week and
was jailed for contempt of court on
corruption-related charges though it's
believed the protests are continuing
because of anger about poverty
and social and economic restrictions
related to covet 19.
anti-government activist groups say more
than 100 cubans have been arrested or
are
unaccounted for after mass protests
there that began on sunday
cuba's communist government has been
cracking down on dissent
[Applause]
protesters have been marching through
the streets of havana demanding an end
to extreme poverty
they're angry about shortages of food
and medicine and general
economic hardship made worse by the
pandemic and u.s
sanctions the crisis in cuba has led to
smaller demonstrations in the u.s
as americans call on the biden
administration to intervene
and drop historic trade sanctions
against cuba
the clock is ticking will canada help
the afghan interpreters who worked
with canadian troops
after weeks of pressure by retired
canadian soldiers the federal government
says it is now working to bring afghan
interpreters to canada
time is running out much of afghanistan
has already fallen back into the control
of the taliban
and those who canadian soldiers trusted
with their lives
need help mike armstrong explains
[Music]
more and more of afghanistan in recent
weeks has fallen
under taliban control government forces
still hold some urban centers but
they've lost
most of the country in terms of
territory the taliban claims to control
about 85 percent the reports are getting
worse
and worse and worse retired canadian
soldier dave morrow says the clock
is ticking he's part of a group that's
been working to pressure the federal
government
to help the afghan interpreters he and
other canadian soldiers
worked alongside men he says who will be
killed
if the taliban reaches them they
have no other option except us
to save them and the lives of their kids
just about everywhere canadian troops
went in afghanistan they went with
locals who knew the territory
and spoke the languages canada had a
program to resettle interpreters and
their families
but it expired in 2011. retired soldiers
have been pushing to have that program
reopened well monday the defense
minister confirmed
that's now happening we right now are
working at
former employees of the canadian armed
forces the afghans have worked with us
and also currently who are working
with global affairs within our embassy
it seems like we got some traction
morrow says the announcement is good
news but that there's a good deal of
work
ahead when the u.s announced earlier
this year would be pulling out of
afghanistan by september 11th
it started fast tracking its
resettlement program it's also planning
airlifts
canada appears to still be planning its
plan
until we actually see something an
action
on the ground for now it's it's still
just words
they want to kill us interpreters
themselves have had their own campaign
in afghanistan
they say they've faced threats for years
but with the u.s now pulling out and
taliban control spreading
hiding from them is getting harder and
harder
like armstrong global news montreal
the stanley cup heads to montreal after
all we'll explain why
next
this is what can happen when you release
your pet goldfish into a lake
these football-sized goldfish were
caught in minnesota they've been
uprooting plants which causes poor water
quality and disrupts the ecosystem
so many have been found recently one
city issued a plea to the public not to
dump unwanted fish saying
they really do grow bigger than you
think
the stanley cup could hold a few
goldfish and who knows maybe it has at
some point
the cup certainly gets around whoever
wins it gets to celebrate with it and in
the heat of the moment
things can happen and in tampa bay
something happened
mike dralet explains
the nhl should have seen the omens when
you combine a jet ski
[Music]
these oddly hypnotic dance moves
and the unfettered abandon of tampa's
russian players
the stanley cup never really had a
chance it hasn't been revealed
what happened but that's a fairly
sizable dent
an irony of ironies montreal may not
have won the cup but is where the nhl's
official engraver lives
so that's where it's going for repairs
for most of the year the cup is handled
with extreme care
so much so that even fingerprints don't
stand a chance
yet cup tradition allows every winning
player to get a full day with stanley
and oh the things it's seen from
kandahar to mountaintops
countless pool parties and babies and
alex ovechkin's bed
the stories add to its lore but is this
one dent too many
it should be like like dropping a casket
or something you know like
people should be down on their knees
praying for forgiveness from the hockey
gods that we damaged the cup
fortunately the damage is repairable and
the cup will return to tampa
in time for the rest of tampa bay's
hometown dates
madness hey stanley
good luck with that mike drew like
global news toronto
[Applause]
and that's global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight sierra
canada is the davis bay pier on bc's
sunshine coast
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
you